Kirby and the rainbow curse is a strange
game and not in the best way its
mechanics are similar to 2005 Nintendo
DS title Kirby canvas cars
it takes its predecessors unique
mechanics but pairs them down into a
game that alternates between boring and
frustrating rainbow curse starts with an
evil force draining all color and life
out of Kirby's homeland so he sets out
through an alternate dimension to stomp
enemies collect stars and get the color
back players guide Kirby through seven
worlds each with three separate stages
and one boss battle on their way to stop
the evil but this isn't the kind of
Kirby game you'd expect
there's no sucking up enemies no
stomping on their heads under the
traditional combat movement instead you
move Kirby using the gamepad stylus
trying rainbow lines on the screen for
him to roll along the direction you draw
the line in is the direction Kirby will
take tapping on Kirby will make him move
faster in the direction he's facing
collecting 100 stars and then holding
down the stylus will make her be
enlarged himself and move faster
allowing him to break thicker materials
like metal and damage larger enemies
it's too simple and too unwieldy Kirby's
physics are floating in rainbow curse
making for a rather uncomfortable
experience corralling him stopping him
from moving getting him to quickly
change directions is a pain you have to
draw your lines quickly and in the right
direction or you could roll Kirby into
certain doom and if Kirby is already on
the move snagging him is even more of a
pain if you run out of magic paint to
draw those lines you're in trouble
death comes easy and rainbow curse if
you have difficulty adapting to this way
of movement
there are also a handful of dedicated
levels in which Kirby becomes a torpedo
shooting submarine or a plane or a
slow-moving tank these levels are the
most infuriating as again you can only
use stylist taps and swipes to guide him
for the submarine tapping in an area
both shoots missiles straight ahead and
moves Kirby in that direction in order
to guide your missiles you need to draw
Rainbow lines they can fly along same
goes for plain Kirby he needs rainbow
tracks to guide him this is where the
difficulty spike and rainbow curse is
most apparent it expects you to adapt to
drawing lines and being a vehicle early
on but doesn't give you much room to
master throwing you into harder
situations to quickly beyond sliding
along rainbows and rolling into enemies
normal Kirby can't do anything no
inhaling no turning to a brick no spin
attack nothing these limitations make
gameplay boring most of the time and
frustrating in the more difficult boss
battles you never really feel like you
have full control of Kirby
it's maddening levels do get
progressively harder as the game goes on
and some of the latter ones are better
with friends rainbow curse lets you play
with up to three companions as Waddle
Dean Kirby's pal waddle dee is more
useful than Kirby in many situations
waddle dee can jump hover for small
periods of time and slash enemies having
a waddle dee or two runs support while
Kirby floats around the screen
collecting stars provides a safety net
playing some of the latter stages solo
feels almost a little scary
luckily the game is generous with 1ups
and health regeneration items but that
doesn't make failure hurt any less
losing a life when you're trying to get
Kirby to safety or avoid an enemy feels
unfair when your movement is bound to a
single track going in one direction it's
difficult to get some hidden
collectibles but honestly there's no
incentive to get them at all nor is
there any fun and playing in challenge
mode where you are given a set of four
stages that lasts 15 seconds each in
each stage you must maneuver through
obstacles to reach a treasure chest fail
to reach the chest in more than one room
and you lose the challenge these rooms
are bite-sized pieces of the tamer
stretches of some levels and their
rewards in-game collectibles aren't
enough to justify the time spent unless
you're a completionist rainbow curse
does have amiibo functionality but it
barely makes a difference with gameplay
tapping a Kirby amiibo to the gamepad
allows you to use kirby star dash at any
time using King Dedede gives Kirby 2
extra health bars and the Meta Knight
amiibo gives Kirby a power boost
but if Kirby dies once loses just 1 life
the bonus is lost and you can only use
one amiibo once per day with rainbow
curse the functionality feels forced in
honestly and is ineffective in the long
run Kirby and the rainbow curse is an OK
game it's beautiful look at filled with
gorgeous bright claymation style
environments and swathes of color but
the beauty is skin-deep its mechanic is
monotonous and at time unreliable making
for a game based on trial and error
that's not very interesting it doesn't
matter how seasoned to vet you are here
Kirby's difficult handling and strict
movement make things unfun